In the last few years, we've
seen a staggering increase
in video consumption, while
worldwide internet bandwidth
hasn't kept the same pace.
My name is Renganathan,
and I'm here
to talk to you about
how the WebM Project is
solving this problem today.
Video accounts for over 50% of
the peak internet bandwidth,
and over 2/3 in certain
parts of the world.
And it's growing fast.
The WebM Project is a collection
of open source media codex
and technologies aimed
to address this problem.
How well does this work?
VP9 can halve the
bit rate compared
to H.264 for the same
quality settings.
This has massive implications
for the web, especially
YouTube, who loves billions of
VP9 play backs to their users.
This is because
YouTube is seeing
both a decrease in
average bitrates,
and an improvement in
quality over H.264.
So what does this mean
to YouTube customers?
VP9 provides a better
streaming experience,
reducing rebuffers by
25% in developed markets,
and a whopping 100%
in emerging markets.
This means videos
to more places.
In fact, because of VP9, we are
able to serve an additional 25%
of videos in HD worldwide,
and they load 15% faster,
which you will notice is
giving YouTube the ability
to add a check box
to stream 4K videos.
And the truth is, working
at YouTube's scale
has allowed us to dramatically
improve VP9 in this past year.
For starters, we've improved
the encoding speed by 40x.
To meet the demands
of YouTube we've
added three new controls
to the encoding process.
The first is variable bitrate,
controlled by the target
bitrate parameter, allows you
to hit specific bitrate values.
Constant quality, controlled
with the CQ level parameter,
allows you to hit specific
quality values for your encode,
while the constraint quality
is a hybrid mode that
allows you to balance
between the two,
allowing you to conserve bitrate
after hitting a quality goal.
To provide even more
control of your encodes,
especially trade off between
computational complexity
and compression
efficiency, you can
use the CPU speed
parameter to navigate.
We are also providing
an additional trade
off point between
speed and encodes
with the functional
1-pass encode option.
Quality wise, this is usually
within a few percentage points
of a 2-pass encode,
with similar settings.
Next up, VP9 has three adaptive
quantization experiments
to adjust bit expenditure
within a frame,
to give better cycle
visual quality.
If you look in more
detail at the large, 64
by 64 blocks in the top center,
at a fixed quantization,
they're spending only a few
bits for the whole region.
In contrast, for some of the
regions down on the tracks,
they're spending
several thousand bits.
The AQ modes try and
correct the balance
a little by reducing expenditure
in these expensive areas,
while where taking a few bits
won't visually hurt much,
and increasing the expenditure
in the easy sections,
like the sky and
hillside, and can overall
improve the visual quality.
Now these are set using the
AQ mode commandline parameter.
And for more information
on how to control
adaptive quantization,
check out webmproject.org.
Now video-on-demand is
a significant proportion
of the video on Internet.
But real time communication
and screen sharing
are very important
to us is as well.
I'm happy to announce that VP9
now has a functioning real time
encode option for video
conferencing and screen
sharing.
At the start of the year,
measured against p negative 5
of VP8 for HD content, VP9
encode was 25 times too slow.
With the addition of a
non-RD path and many other
optimizations, this is
now down to about 2x,
but delivering about
40% compression gains,
or about 1.4x, delivering
about 20% compression gains.
Now real time enables
screen sharing applications
to use VP9, however,
screen sharing
requires high fidelity text
and color space rendering.
Towards this, we're also
announcing experimental support
for 4:4:4 and 4:2:2
color profiles to VP9.
Now we heard you loud and clear
that you needed simpler tools
to encode videos into WebM.
So we announced a
few open source tools
to make these process better.
Check out Demystifying WebM
Encodes and Decodes for tips,
tricks, and tools to encode
and play back WebM files.
The team has been hard at
work making decode better,
especially on mobile,
with a strong focus
on multicore performance and
improvements to battery life.
We've made VP9 decode over seven
times faster since June, 2013.
In fact, we can do consistent,
continuous, 1080p play
back on your Nexus 5.
And over 10 companies
have licensed the VP9 RTF
for adding fixed-function
hardware decode,
including MediaTek and Nvidia.
Now this means that you have
low power, 2160p, 60 frames
per second decode
in devices in 2015.
Finally, we began work on our
new high bit depth profile
for VP9, which would support
both 10-bit and 12-bit video.
You can follow its progress
on webmproject.org,
and we're doing this
work in two phases.
In the first phase,
all internal buffers
will be upgraded to 16-bits,
along with all filtering.
But your input and output
would still be 8-bits.
With the higher
internal position
we expect some
huge coding gains.
In the second phase we
will increase the precision
of the transfer
coefficients to add extra 2-
or 4-bits of precision, and make
other changes as appropriate
for the bitstream syntax.
We anticipate that
work on the HBD profile
will be concluded
by the fall of 2014.
Now we worked very hard to
make VP9 an open project,
and to help you
provide a great video
experience through the web,
across many of these devices.
Now it's your turn to
start telling great video
stories on the internet.
For more information on creating
and playing back WebM videos,
check out "Demystifying
WebM Encode and Decodes."
And as always, we
are here to help.